a lot of experimentation Klein is
rockets and Hardaway miss throws down
the follow your folks see right there
but didn't quit on the plate so nice
recovery to block the shot foul by the
way was on Dotson right then I'll hustle
not out muscled oh la place to Robinson
and then stolen a couple what a block by
Mitchell Robinson
Collison getting up so New York is going
to have numbers five on to it the other
way bonaly pulls the three enjoys it I
thought Collison got fouled on this but
good reaction and recovery by Robinson
to ignite the break wasn't the credit
position that they have today
seventh floor refers done mesmerising
under four minutes remaining
next late 5:15 this is last tisha have a
knocked away by Robertson second
opportunities here now the Wizards
Friday night Kline they went to play 10
in the opening tenants blocked by
Robinson tips at the backcourt
sometimes when you slow it down you
realize as Robinson goes up and throws
it down
perfect pass and a great finish from a
rookie now two quick fouls
here's Bembry into the paint protected
by Robinson in four and using it
magnificently that time likes the block
with the left hand and veteran defensive
players don't want some undrafted rookie
rabbit's it throws it down perfect
capture their the Thunder after that own
four start playing really well and
that's a Nick Ricci record watch it get
up you down but not out and the nick of
time to reject the shot he breaks the
rookie record by kristaps porzingis
Salani shelton point when you got the
fenders back and squared in the back is
pull it out and run something through
two throws it inside grant blocked again
by Mitchell Robbins if they heard
[Music]
[Applause]
grupe ties the most of the league
rejected this one while mixing it in
transition
[Applause]
ramps at home
Robinson feastin up the good dition at
rear rows here another rejection by
Robinson very inhospitable net / throws
rocks at trappers it down perfect
connection first half for the next one
down the third trio throws it up
[Applause]
let's--oh awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oops them at the defensive end
everybody's energized because
everybody's touching the ball
Morris dresser there that's his third of
the game we've seen in these folks these
thing we have to get down to get up here
predicted the lady for Robinson look at
Robinson slamming and jamming with your
right hand it's still important to be
aggressive right now on the offensive
side Trier in the lane leading it up for
Mitchell Robinson welcome back
[Applause]
driving spinning through swatted away by
Mitchell Robinson so ten players have
already receive minutes here how did you
justify that though Mike renewed we're
thrown those thoughts
[Applause]
when I played the all-star break with
symbolical midseason again second time
they've connected on a beautiful Alice
to continues to sit on the bench
Makena the drive inside a Robinson
Robinson throws it down it's taking
advantage of the lack of height Robinson
goes to double team and then explores a
gentleman this is the Carolis past my
heart nila keenan gonna have to hustle
and bustle a clear heart away on the
floor together pockets it roll into the
room and the slam Robertson retaliates
this time Dotson overcommits Hinson
blocked by Robertson fourth block for
Robinson we've just got strength
powerful player
neophyte has been a delight with his
shot-blocking folks stearic you by
Parker there let Dan that's right
you see the right side will you back up
to a tree or rabbits and they do it
again beautiful connection you can look
at tree and Robinson now good ESB on
this slamming engendered it comes month
another player with Street Allen
Robinson his second rejection I'm sad
blocked a couple of times
Robinson showing this though sky and get
an easy opportunity stops uh space come
in is what gets a clock by Robinson
perfect timing again here comes Allen
Robinson hands it off to be balanced
Rose it up rabbits at Rose it down and
the foul
beautiful roll to the basket then Alan
with a perfect pass
watch this previously missed the layup
off the glass
this time created for his teammate not
having much of an impact on the defense
he's got to continue to finish it
there's usually one per game Lance
Thomas Insider Robinson gathers he's
moved up to 21st on the all-time scoring
list Allen throws it up and wrap up and
sit right away on the court for about
four seconds immediately with one of
those lob catches and finishes not the
thing to do that time finishing last in
swishing making up for it tonight though
especially with the alley-oop put Avonex
wise to take time off the clock
[Applause]
now you can dominate on both ends of the
court previously intimidating mills
makin em misfire
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
from Mitchell Robinson emphatic ending
here put a Nick's watch the
razzle-dazzle on pickmonz
John Jenkins this is a game Ellingson
throws offensive
everybody getting into the lie back in
terms of passing it to Mitchell Robinson
Boynton Robinson is on the court the
actually slows down the paint for the
opposition there's the first Dalio for
the Diamonds throwing up because
Robinson gets them sometimes even when
the passes aren't the best deal inches 7
1 7 3 wingspan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so Robinson harassin that sound almost
blocked with the finish to catch enough
to do he started to do it he's had a
major impact defensively the Alioto
Robinson and the oohs and ahhs when he
throws it down with such ferocity
[Music]
there's a legit defended by temple my
farm eight four consider ferocious lamb
he said some stretches where he looks
terrific Robinson came in at the fall
gets his own rebound of troubles in town
there's again another part of the growth
of Mitchell Robinson there's Priya's
driving issue golf color Robinson's land
team driving on Knox let live again
that's number five there's stiff junior
ahead of the field take on Xavier on
Thursday afternoon
lately with five straight minutes to get
to the tourney there's been four
Robinson that's his second block the
Washington rejected previously sabonis
scored on sequence for Mitchell Robinson
[Applause]
[Music]
the core runs and takes it away and a
big finish in a very nice pass on the
move by hezonia why he's a rookie
Robinson with a nice catch above the
waist but they were stuck on the one two
or three for an exceptionally long time
[Applause]
good defense well that's because the
pump exchanges who's in and out of the
lineup the momentum slipping away from
the next wave
the house that's his third rejection got
a superstar three times then always
looking to get into pain in the stands
that the United Center was wonderful
evening
[Music]
dennah well house jr. for the Rockets
sharpeners played 18 games for the
Rockets coming for his defensive prowess
the slab by Robert Schendel
the Datsun homecoming he was off to a
good start in the first quarter
Robertson the finish they make it look
so easy at times the pick and roll take
a look at Robinson
jinkins an exquisite pass to Robinson
yeah a very vociferous crowd at the
Garden tonight here into the game
second-to-last hold the game for the
excess box sets up Robinson 22 years ago
[Applause]
nasty sassy stuff by Robertson every
game short something different
porosity hostility Smith jr. and the
black box at the finish
when they release to create a roster
spot release tellenson dachshund throws
up and Robinson with a left hand
something to build upon and you have
players of parity but for one he's been
in the league for so long I don't again
I mean he's been in the league for so
long and just being able to experience
things average 15.3 points per game 37%
three-point shooting knocks great time
inside and the flush by Mitchell
Robinson expressed herself Ashley Dunn
he attacks the closeout draws the second
defense better get Fran Fraschilla we
need Fran Fraschilla
nice look underneath by knocks Cavanaugh
and Robinson punching it home with two
fists when you're as talented going
downhill and it's versatile as our tape
areas for a guy like RJ that's a pretty
simple formula look at that look at
there he's keep trying to shoot over
come on Robinson just tempting shooters
to shoot it than this game especially at
the defensive end
caught this one
and only fitting that he would be on the
other end another outstanding eye
contact
yes NYX looking to run Barrett feeds
Cavanaugh for a kitchen shoot triple if
the trailer is running and he isn't
blocked out that's what you get what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content